operation varsity blues culminated early
this morning we're talking about
deception and fraud fake test scores
fake athletic credentials fake
photographs bribed college officials
fans were left completely stunned on
Tuesday when Felicity Huffman and Lori
Lachlan were among 50 people charged in
what prosecutors are calling the largest
college admission scam ever a
spokeswoman for the FBI confirmed to ET
that Felicity was arrested on Tuesday
morning without incident at her LA area
home
Lori was taken into custody earlier this
morning and is due to appear in federal
court this afternoon as you can imagine
this new sparked a big conversation on
social media so much so that Lauri
deleted her Instagram how on Becky was
trending everywhere big time even some
of her fellow celebrities jumped in on
the conversation including Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star Kyle
Richards
whose daughter Sophia recently started
attending college at George Washington
University here's what she had to say on
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
we know a lot of people in that circle
and it was really shocking today and you
know Sophia knows all those girls and
you're friends with Lori yeah and there
are really great people and you kind of
go I'm a little confused by it by all of
this and yeah you know sort of like it's
everyone's talking about it today you
know in our world and also in our circle
but we you know until today had never
heard that's never existed you know
maybe I'm naive I didn't even know that
existed
et obtained Court docs on Tuesday which
details the allegations against the
dozens of people who are accused of
paying thousands and even millions of
dollars to get their kids into elite
schools across the country including
University of Southern California
Georgetown Yale and Stanford both
Felicity and Lori have been charged with
one felony count of mail fraud and ET
sat down with law and crime network
president Rachel Stockman who explained
what legal repercussions they could face
it is a felony so they could face jail
or prison
time however I would expect that they
would probably just face a hefty fine if
they were convicted felicity is accused
of paying $15,000 so that her 18
year-old daughter Sofia would have twice
the amount of time to complete her SAT
exam then her answers were allegedly
corrected Felicity's husband William H
Macy was not charged but arrived to
court on Tuesday ahead of Felicity's
hearing so in the case of Lori Loughlin
she's accused of conspiring with this
guy in California paid him a
half-a-million dollars to get her two
daughters into college coach said that
they were members of a crew team when
they weren't so so they got into college
under false pretenses
Lori's husband Massimo was also charged
their daughters Isabella and Olivia are
both enrolled at USC Olivia as you might
know as a successful youtuber who posted
this video last year
I'm literally moving into college today
I do want the experience of like game
days partying I don't really care about
school as you guys don't know et spoke
to Lauri in 2016 and talked about the
importance of sending her two daughters
to college I want them to be happy so I
want to be supportive of everything they
want to do but I do want them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
of high school college experience maybe
because I didn't have that I would
really want that for them of course this
story is still developing so make sure
to subscribe to all things ET and we'll
keep you up to date with the latest in
the meantime i'm courtney tezo no and
I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]